all they wanted to get is the truth
just the facts
no bull
tense words exchanged at a meeting to
sort out what went wrong with an
investigation into the death of a unlv
student thank you for joining us at six
i'm bryan loftis and i'm denise valdez
an investigation into a deadly
fraternity boxing match is now complete
but a fight is still continuing outside
the ring as the head of the commission
tears into metro this is a story the
eight news now i-team first broke the
i-team's vanessa murphy here now the
very latest fallout from an
investigative report she first obtained
denise and brian the nevada attorney
general's office says metro police
failed to investigate whether foul play
was involved in the deadly fraternity
boxing match metro police insist they
did review the case and as mentioned
that meeting was tense
are you going to come in and do the
right thing
i'm asking you to answer binary
questions either yes or no
you represent metro
you're here we appreciate that very much
it doesn't seem like it nevada state
athletic commission chairman stephen
klubeck addressing metro deputy chief
james la rochelle after the release of
this report the nevada attorney
general's office investigated this
fraternity boxing match in november
twenty-year-old nathan valencia a unlv
student seen here in red headgear
collapsed after his match and died from
head injuries a key finding identified
in the report a failure by metro to look
into whether foul play was involved did
you do a homicide investigation
sir i'm trying did you i'm asking a
question we did not do a homicide
investigation deputy chief la rochelle
saying that's after input from the clark
county district attorney's office here's
chairman klubeck addressing assistant
d.a christopher lawley i received a copy
of the report this morning
and i am not in any position whatsoever
to comment on the report
how could you come to a meeting
when you got a certified letter
from this commission
putting you on notice
that you were being talked about you're
not prepared i didn't
know you just said you're not prepared
you said you didn't read anything and
you're not prepared
i didn't receive a copy of the report
that means you're not prepared
as first reported by the i.t monday
investigators listed numerous protocols
which weren't followed at the
unregulated event commissioner anthony
marnell calls it an underground fight
this is a cluster beyond belief from one
end to the other on
organization promotion
safety inspection
drugs alcohol in the ring i mean it
really a referee drinking in the ring
the report also raises questions about
valencia's opponent emanuel ailman
investigators say they were able to
examine all gear used at the event
except for his witnesses said his hands
were wrapped long before the fight this
is one of his attorneys jordan logan if
you have the gloves just tend to run
don't know games you want to play games
there's no games just tender them
tomorrow i want the gloves tomorrow
tomorrow please we'd love to have the
gloves tomorrow have them ask we i'm
asking you right now
we'd love to have them tomorrow please
can we have them tomorrow please i will
talk to my client on monday illman's
attorneys told the i-team they advised
him not to speak with investigators but
now
it begs the question though why not
speak to investigators
who
who should we have spoken to the
attorney general's office for the
investigation general's office just said
they didn't get the case until
months later the
metro didn't have the case who were we
supposed to talk to
the attorney general's office was doing
the investigation so why not
speak to them
there was no refusal to speak to the
attorney general's office
if investigators want to talk to emanuel
now will you advise him to talk to them
or
they can reach out to me and we will
discuss with them
whatever it is they'd like to discuss
and this just in from the valencia
family they are pleased with the
findings and appreciate the attorney
general office's efforts they also hope
the nevada legislature implements
changes to ensure events like this never
happen again so far nathan's law helps
close a loophole in the regulation of
student matches but the commission also
acknowledges more needs to be done metro
police released a statement a short
while ago calling the hearing
unprofessional and unproductive also
saying the department is willing to
assist the attorney general's office if
they want to move forward with any
criminal prosecution denise back to you